hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to breach and clean the game
where you're gonna get that room clean
no matter who gets in your way you gotta
blow your way into the room
you gotta put explosives on the door and
blast your way into the room and then
clean as fast as you're capable of doing
at least I think the trailer for this
game was a weird live-action one that
was actually really cool so I'm gonna go
for it wheee
okay I don't know how to play yeah oh
[ __ ] what about that one no it's locked
how about this one what am I doing with
these goddamn towels get out of my face
I've got a room to clean I pull this I
know it's a push only yeah huh what what
what have you who is what hey I've got
an attitude about that floating penis
above your head oh I'm fired Am I oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you and [ __ ] you oh
just cuz i intruded on someone
masturbating there giant floating dick
above their head I get fired okay
whatever moving on moving on moving on
BAM op miss your hello from lazing in
the promo Oh
junk poison in the Brummer sorry I did
not know housekeeping housekeeping how
about mom hello oh that's a lot of
stains a lot of very questionable how
did not mean it
Barton I'm sorry I'm gonna try to clean
all right here oh don't mind these
motions hmm okay you didn't see anything
did you I didn't see anything
judge into Gibran's gray what blacks
look belong way okay that guy's that
guy's busy so let's try not that how
about this one Oh get out of my face get
oh my god my face there we go
I did good I'll be giving it a look at
this one yeah oh my eyeballs exploded
okay so I gotta get the trash into twist
can [ __ ] I did it I got a mop
good thing there was no one in here or
else I would have been heavily disturbed
who all shop I'll put that there
floating in the middle of my cart is the
best place for that how about some hot
fresh towels yeah yeah it's good enough
pick up the can
[Music]
lamb done and done
nice and clean Oh God
Oh what do they do to this thing huh get
out of here Oh Nelly good thing I got
two replacement for this ha bye Emma
okay so the brown ones is the bad ones
whoa bouzouki oh I'm the master of
disaster cleaning disaster that is all
done how am I supposed to be able to get
out this guy's an [ __ ] he's in there
oh I guess I got to put in mine mm-hmm
I guess I got to just deal with not
having that clean then I'm done
take me home why do I have mops floating
in the middle of the hallway over there
that doesn't seem logical Monsieur
do you need some toilet paper I don't
Kwai oh don't mind me
no my gosh it ah no no no it okay it
okay okay huh
Jesus really dear Little Miss owl this
owl how about a bomb for your bath it's
called a bath bomb ever it's all the
rave Wow the monk is Quine I know I know
pump quake let's ow bless up what did
you break what did you break
Lana hey no no no no it's fine it's fine
- fine you don't remember a thing do you
need anything in there okay I got that
one we're all good I just left a few
bombs around here all right we're good
let's get outta here
we did it all right first floor done
with a bonus mate oh [ __ ] another one
goddamn it hello housekeeping he's just
sleeping well now's my chance to murder
him with a BAM or mop don't wake up
oh just cuz I'll shouting soon yeah well
that's not mop worthy that's not mop
worthy at all yeah domani don't mind me
sir ah boink boink hey so I just gotta
get her [ __ ] just got well [ __ ] just got
it well [ __ ] ah there we go got it
excuse me miss y'all I'm embarrassing
you're embarrassing
hey welcome Quay no I don't think so I
only weapon quay the best of them and
you can go up and Quay yourself oh whoa
hello Oh God
don't mind me Stephie it's messy oh so
many stains why so many stains what did
you do
oh my mate don't mommy okay I'll go in
another door real quick oh it's locked
well that ain't gonna stop me oh ah oh
there's no one in here
oh there's no one in here at all there's
no need to rush huh we said fun ah plus
key not done not done what could
possibly more need to be done
the Fahd whoo because I could drain him
ah there we go all done let's get home
baby get home
ah you know faster than this if I use my
explosives it would be so easy
I am dunzo done Yin rings Oh another one
all right here we go this one's gonna
take some doing all right we got a
double banger well [ __ ] I didn't need to
do that
we got trouble banger apparently because
I feel extra explosive
yeah oh there's no one in here again oh
[ __ ] sorry
sorry about that I blasted them into
oblivion do we have more mopping ah
anyone staining ah row stains bruh how
about in here
stay off somebody stains what's with the
stains laces ones done get done flip
that floppy flip that floppy don't mind
me I hope you get blasted with this
plosives sorry you seem to have dropped
oh [ __ ] well that's a mistake
welcome Krab indeed I'm sorry
was that me I apologize for you try and
sleep off our cue are you alright can i
okay I'll come back to you later sir
we're doing oh hey there's no stains in
here oh sorry sir you all right probably
not no no no no no no no no don't worry
sorry you seem to be suffering from a
not exploding problem now have a good
night okay what about the douche in here
was there a douche in here Bing Bing
Bing oh it's open you didn't oh my god
oh I just need to put an extra explosive
on here just in case yeah you slob don't
do my me go good enough good enough okay
I'm out here that's all I needed to do
BAM okay Oh once I'm not done I'm not
done Oh what did this [ __ ] need I
don't know what he needs
what does he need doesn't need anything
Oh what he doesn't need anything it's a
bunch of lies what an [ __ ]
there's nothing to be done [ __ ] you man
there's nothing to be done there's
nothing else here god damn it there's
nothing else in there and all these are
merely adequate they're not perfect but
I'm not perfect so hmm maybe there's
some secret mop
going on oh really oh really it just
needed a slight dab of a mop so that it
would be done I guess I'm done here okay
screw you Oh screw you oh wow I gotta
close the goddamn door oh good night I
miss you're alright now I'm done
oh come on I not closed this one hey
there we go now we're done okay we're
good work out of work out of work out
for good BAM ah come on I'm done they're
all adequate I know they're not perfect
but they're adequate and I mean I like
to pride myself in being adequate not
perfect
oh my toilet paper is spinning out of
control
well well sack of [ __ ] that I am at
least my thing cause a great big stain
for the next [ __ ] that comes by and
tries to clean your goddamn hotel but
either way that is breach and clean it's
oddly enough pretty fun it reminds me of
viscera cleanup detail which I haven't
played for a long time but either way if
you like games about janitorial duties
this one might be the one for you so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye